bonjour à reprendre confiance en soi
grâce au théâtre c'est tout l'enjeu de
cet atelier à la ferme de bel ébat
depuis quinze jours c'est une dizaine de
demandeurs d'emploi qui se retrouvent
tous les jours pour monter leur propre
pièce de théâtre c'est essayer de former
un groupe une cohésion de groupe que
celle ordonnée confiance essayer de
faire en sorte qu'ils osent parce qu'ils
arrivent tous en dix ans mais je
voudrais pas monter sur scène donc on a
quinze jours pour pour les pour rendre
les personnes plus confiante et se dire
que non ils vont oser on faire hommes
femmes jeunes ou âgées sur scène on
retrouve tous les profils loin d'être
inactif
on rencontre des apprentis comédiens
avec le désir de travailler rencontre
des gens qui y sont actifs en tout cas
qu'ils veulent l'être qui veulent bouger
qui veulent travailler qui veulent
montrer ils arrivent à l'heure c'est
quand même un gros travail continue à
travailler chez eux
je suis capable moi qui serais moi qui a
échappé très tôt à ma cité quand on est
sur une scène il faut pouvoir pas voir
on ne s'exprime il faut assumer il faut
il faut être entendu il faut c'est
quelque chose que moi j'ai du mal moulin
vie de tous les jours donc c'est ça me
permet de reprendre confiance en moi et
d'être beaucoup plus communiquant avec
les autres car tu sais que tu ne veux
plus ta vie d'avant et ça c'est sûr
c'est pas franchement évident mais mais
c'est plaisant et on va voir le résultat
après une semaine d'écriture et une
semaine de mise en scène tous ces
efforts seront récompensés
la troupe se produira devant un public
mardi soir pour la première partie d'une
pièce professionnels